you said in reaction to hotter than
expected inflation data gold rose
eighteen dollars closing near one
thousand eight hundred fifty dollars per
ounce it's the highest level in five
months but while bitcoin initially
pumped to a new all-time high close to
69 000 the ensuing dump sent it tumbling
8.5 back below 63 000 at the low the
point i was making uh anthony
the point i was making you're squirming
is that
gold gold actually reacted to higher
inflation by going up bitcoin reacted to
it by going down now what happened
initially is i think some of the whales
that want to unload bitcoin the minute
they saw that hot print they're like
okay let's buy some bitcoin and try to
get some excitement around this
inflation number gold's going up let's
make bitcoin go up and they come in
there and they buy and they get people
oh you see even my son got excited look
dad look at bitcoin going up on the
inflation numbers right so they got all
this excitement and as soon as they got
the herd all excited then they dumped it
right they took advantage of the pump
and they came out big time selling their
bitcoin and it went crashing down so i
think the whole initial move up was all
the manipulated attempt to unload
bitcoin it wasn't like ah you see
bitcoin is reacting to the inflation is
bitcoin's got nothing to do with
inflation it's not inflation hedge it's
not a commodity it's not a real asset
you know it's just it's just a you know
it's it's a risk asset and it goes up
when people want to buy it you know it
doesn't get anything to do with
inflation but anything to do with other
commodities i don't have anything to do
with the gold but obviously that's part
of the story that's part of the phony
narrative that's used to generate demand
for bitcoin is that it's gold uh and but
they were able to manipulate it up but
the fact that it got killed so strongly
uh shows you that there are people that
were waiting to sell
that spike and i think the people who
sold it are the same people who helped
create it now maybe they didn't use the
same wallets you know maybe they have
some wallets where they buy and then
they have other wallets where they dump
uh but it seemed to me that that's
exactly what was going on
all right are you last question for you
and then we got to go we got other
things to do you were late so you know i
got i got all kinds of i wasn't late you
didn't send us the link no i sent you
the link six times uh did are you
changing anything about your portfolio
after the uh cpi print yesterday
no i mean my portfolio went up you know
be you know although you know
interestingly the dollar the dollar went
up and again that shouldn't be happening
the dollar had a big update yesterday on
the cpi which of course inflation
lets you know that the dollar is losing
value so the fact that the dollar is
losing purchasing power faster is not
bullish for the dollar it's bearish but
again the currency traders bid up the
dollar because they expect the fed to
successfully fight off inflation they're
wrong as i said earlier so you know but
i'm short the dollar and that all of my
investments are international so i have
all my stuff in asia and europe and
australia new zealand you know south
america so i i got these foreign assets
but by and large uh my most of my
foreign stocks were up yesterday even as
the u.s market was down but the biggest
winners were the gold stocks they're all
up again today but now you know some of
my copper stocks and uh you know are
having a bigger a bigger days today than
than than my gold stocks uh you know i
also have a lot of energy exposure i
have a lot of assets that i think are
going to be real inflation hedges that's
why i don't own any bitcoin i don't
think bitcoin is an inflation hedge even
though some people think it is uh you
know it's i think i look at bitcoin like
any of these other overpriced meme
stocks i mean they can keep going up uh
so long as you know the crowd uh you
know is going to believe the story
but eventually
you know reality sets in i'm just not
smart enough to know when